a landmark year that's how Lloyd's wants
us to think about 2017 there was a big
jump in four-year pre-tax profits to a
record 5.3 billion pounds although that
was slightly below city expectations and
the bank will return more than three
billion pounds to shareholders but yet
more money was set aside for PPI and the
bosses six million pound pay packet has
raised eyebrows well that man group
chief executive Antonia hot asorio joins
me now Antonio thank you for joining me
now this is probably the best showing
since the the financial crisis it's been
a long long haul well it was really a
landmark year for Lloyds the in the last
year of our second strategic plan we
were able to create a largest digital
Bank in the UK we now have more than 13
million customers online that by far the
largest bank in the UK we were able to
return to full private ownership and
gave taxpayers money back and some more
and finally as as we just heard we have
increased our dividends and retribution
to shareholders by 46 percent in the
year amounting to 3.2 billion pounds the
largest ever capital distribution from
Lloyds to shareholders I guess if
there's one blemish on these numbers
it's a fact that there's yet another PPI
provision I mean that August cut off
next year can't come quick enough can it
well we just provision according to past
behavior there was an FCA campaign that
raised awareness and rightly so said
customers can get their money back ahead
of the deadline that was the purpose of
the campaign that meant 600 million
pounds in the quarter now I mentioned
the distribution to shareholders worth
pointing out you probably the most
widely held company in the in the
country millions of shareholders yes we
are by far the largest health company in
the come in the country we have two
point four million shareholders why are
you paying doing a share buyback rather
than paying out a special dividend well
that's an interesting question I mean
the board given we had a significant
capital surplus the board after do
thoughts and consideration thought that
we should on one hand increase the
ordinary dividend substantially we
increased the ordinary dividend by 20
percent versus the total cash dividend
paid last year that is a dividend yield
of around
four and a half percent and given that
we still had some additional cash
available the board thought that we
should distribute it as a buyback
because some of our investors like for
example American investors and others
prefer buybacks so in that in that sense
we had enough capital to please both of
our types of shareholders right now the
big news today is that you've announced
your next three-year strategy you're
targeting a return on equity between 14
and 15 percent we're only at 8.9 at the
moment that's gonna be quite a stretch
isn't it well we are at eight point nine
percent return on tangible equity but
our underlying return after tax is
already fifteen point six percent as we
continue to increase our profits and as
we finish the legacy issues of the past
the statutory return on equity will
reach the underlying return on equity so
we are very confident that's why we have
actually increased our guidance about
returns we increase it to between
fourteen and fifteen percent from
previously thirteen and a half percent
to fifteen but on a higher capital basis
because now we will have a capital
requirement of thirteen percent plus one
percent management buffer so we are
increasing the return guidance on the
higher capital base and we are very
confident that we will achieve it and I
looking to take 15 percent RG a
cost-based year the next three years a
lot of people will say oh that means
more branch closures
well we haven't announced that target
actually what we said is that for the
next three years what we are going to do
is number one we are going to keep the
largest retail bank in the UK and the
largest digital bank we want to increase
further and we are going to do the
biggest investment in the business and
in our clients and in our colleagues
ever we are going to invest more than
three billion pounds over the next plan
period in the next three years which is
the largest amount ever and that is
going to enable us on one hand to
continue to develop our digital Bank we
want to have more than 15 million
customers by 2020 number two we are
going to significantly increase our
presence in the
financial planning and retirement space
where we were we are significantly under
represented and thirdly we are going to
make the bank more agile with the new
technologies with artificial
intelligence we wanted to do an absolute
into n transformation of the bank and
prepare the bank to succeed in a digital
world
but you're not ruling out more branch
closures I'm not ruling out because what
we do in terms of branches or any other
thing in the bank is we follow what our
customers want branches are incredibly
important for us we have the largest
branch network in the country and we are
going to keep it our target is to keep a
21 percent market share of branches of
course what those branches do will have
to be different in the future they will
have to provide more complex needs of
our customers more value-added needs
such as advice for mortgages for
first-time buyers or financial planning
and retirement advice or more needs from
our business banking customers and what
we will do is to follow what our
customers want and they are growing lis
interacting with us on a multi-channel
approach but exponentially more through
digital that's why we have more than 13
million digital customers Maundy I mean
you are the big UK's biggest lender as
we said biggest mortgage provider you're
very much geared to the UK economy how
do you view the health of the UK economy
right now well this is a strategy we
took six years ago and it has proved to
be exactly the right strategy the main
purpose of Lloyds is to help Britain
prosper we had 30 countries six years
ago we have sold those positions we have
concentrated the bank in the United
Kingdom 97% of what we do is done in the
UK and we have sold what we had in asset
management international private banking
what we do is to support the real
economy the families the businesses and
the communities of the country and
therefore what happens to the UK economy
is absolutely critical for us and that's
why the fact that we are completely
focused on helping Britain prosper is
good for us and for the UK economy the
two objectives are inextricably linked
and what we have seen is that the
economy is in good shape GDP has been
growing at 1.8% and grew over the last
few years with less leverage in the
economy and at the same time with rising
house prices how do I see it for the
next 12 months well on one hand given
the pounds depreciation inflation has
been rising and above disposable income
which is affecting consumption but on
the other hand employment has never been
higher continues to grow and that helps
consumption and the same part
depreciation helps exports to the
European Union and to the rest of the
world and finally the word growth is now
increasing we are at big open economy
and we benefit from the world growth as
well so all in all my best predictions
here now my best prediction is that the
GDP growth will be reasonably the same
over the next 12 months
like it has been in the past 12 months I
just want to ask you very very briefly
Jeremy Corbyn made a speech yesterday
and he said banks need to be the servant
of industry not the masters of us all
that's a bit of a dig at your industry
isn't it yeah I read these declarations
and he says exactly that and he said
that banks should focus on the real
economy which is exactly what Lord is
doing as I just told you
I mean Lloyd's purpose is to absolutely
help Britain prosper and to help the
real economy which are the families and
the business of this country to give you
an example in the last seven years we
have supported SME net lending by an
additional eight billion pounds while
the Bank of England numbers showed the
sector as a whole having decreased 20
billion pounds so our support to small
and medium-sized businesses which are
the lifeblood of the country in terms of
employment and exports has been massive
and our market share increased from 13
to 19 percent in that segment all right
and Terre Haute so sorry I gotta leave
it there great to see you thank you